really really want to get to Lee and
Chrissy Hicks parents of Yulia Hicks
this 14 year old girl who needs the
kidney transplant Lee and Chrissy are
both army veterans they are parents to
11 children eight biological children
and three adopted children we want to
talk family goals this is like the
family this is the family that I suspect
we all aspire to okay they live in North
Carolina they homeschool their kids
they're doing everything right they are
so grounded here and all they are asking
is that the medical establishment give
their daughter basic treatment
and the this Medical Center The Duke
University Children's Hospital
is
behaving in a way that is simply evil I
don't I don't know how Austria is just
evil to say yeah oh you need you like
that kid mate oh you like your daughter
you want your daughter to live okay take
the shot
take the shot that we lied to you about
for two years take the shot that has
killed people that has killed a lot of
people actually okay and that's not a
conspiracy theory that's well attested
too at this point even even the the
medical establishment will admit it in
some moments of Candor okay and and take
take the shot that has I I think been
shown to complicate things such as organ
donation take it because we tell you to
and if we and if you don't do what we
tell you to do we're gonna take your kid
from you Lee Chrissy thank you for
coming on the show thank you for having
us uh so awful uh what you're going
through obviously you've got my sympathy
and I'm sure sympathy everybody out
there
before we figure out how to fix it
what exactly has Duke been telling you
well we've been seeing um by the Duke
doctors for her dialysis of the last two
years once the coveted vaccine became I
guess approved for children I think that
was in March last year they started
saying like do you want to give her the
shot do you want to give it a shot we
kept pushing back and saying no we're
not going to do the shot and they would
say well you're not going to get a
transplant without it and I just kept
telling a mobile crossed that bridge
when we get there let's just focus on
doing you know dialysis with her she
fought covid in January of 2022 24 hours
it was a very mild case no problems and
she she got over it right away so we've
always been pushing back against this
shot
of course what is the argument here to
get it because I remember when the shot
first came out the fauces of the world
were insisting that everybody get it and
then everyone get the second one and
everyone get the third one because it
was so effective that you had to get
like five of them and but then but then
even medical doctors even people from
the big medical establishment
institutions came out and admitted
actually kovid doesn't pose this huge
risk to younger people actually some of
the vaccines seem to pose a greater risk
specifically to younger people than
covid does this is why the use of the
vaccine has been banned places all over
the world for people under the age of 30
for teenagers so I how do they even look
at you with a straight face and say your
14 year old girl who faces statistically
zero risk from covid she has to take the
shot or we won't give her a kidney they
don't give her an explanation at all and
they just tell us if that's where the
cdc's recommendations changed in October
and that's when they said okay now
you're gonna have to get the shot if you
want they say it's not a recommend or a
requirement but it is because they say
it's just uh highly recommended but you
can't get the kitty without getting the
vaccination and so it is a requirement
they're just paying semantics with words
and up until October they were doing
kidney transplants without the vaccine
we know that for a fact we have one of
the guys reached out to us and told us
he received a kidney without the vaccine
in October so it was up until October
this past October they were doing that
and all of a sudden they changed their
tone and make it a requirement
and then they don't give us an
explanation they said you don't get the
kidney if you don't get the vaccination
that's an amazing trick of language they
say it's a recommendation but it's
actually a requirement because the
medical centers say well we are going to
force you to follow all the CDC
recommendations so the CDC gets to get
away with saying no no we're not
requiring it but in practice this is
required for everybody so what is your
opposition to your daughter getting the
vaccine is it medical is it religious is
it political is it all of the above as
we say can it be all the above
um so we've always requested medical I
mean religious exemptions for all the
vaccines that have aborted fetal cell
lines we've done it with all of our
children
um this is no different however
um there's just so much evidence
mounting about the dangers of this
vaccine I mean it you really have to be
blind or turning a blind eye if you
don't see how much is happening with
this vaccine on top of that we've done a
lot of research on our own and found
care of your articles that are showing
that there is a higher risk of rejection
with solid organ transplant if they've
been vaccinated so I guess I would have
to say all the above of course of course
makes makes perfect sense but as we've
we were just discussing earlier today
there is now a major attack on religious
liberty uh coming from the Congress and
coming from the White House I mean this
bill that they just signed the respect
for Marriage Act effectively uh
prohibits Christian Jewish Muslim and
ordinary agnostic people from refusing
to participate in a so-called gay
marriage in public life I mean it's it's
though the the headline seems to be this
is about marriage it's ultimately really
about suppressing religion and that's
true in many ways of the covid vaccine
they're very strong bioethical religious
moral Arguments for not taking this
vaccine and in most areas of public life
you look at the military exemptions you
look at government exemptions they try
to do it even with private sector
exemptions the the powers that they say
too bad I don't care take your take your
religion and stuff it so is this just a
Duke problem or is this
any medical center you could go to
well no say there's so there are other
children hospitals in North Carolina
that require the same thing right kidney
transplant you cannot get the kidney
transplant without the vaccination which
makes no sense to me but there are
places in Texas and Florida that will do
it without so it's being done in this
country without it's not like we're
putting her life in danger by not
following the doctors that know how to
do transplants that's not what we're
getting at but there are other places
that are doing it in fact Duke was doing
it just three months ago they were
giving transplants to unvaccinated
patients and now suddenly we are being
excluded from that and we have been
finding this man in other ways too so we
had to fight the Mandate for our kids to
go to college without getting a shot
this isn't the first time we've had to
fight the mandates right right of course
no we did it at the daily wire we ended
up suing the federal government we were
the first company to to bring this
lawsuit that mercifully that one we won
some of the other lawsuits about the
military exemptions and all the rest uh
that those did not work out but the one
that we were on we won and we did it
because we said well what are we going
going to do if if the government does
come down and say you as a business have
to mandate this for your employees
we would have to go along with it or
close up shop there was no other option
because the the fees could end up being
hundreds of thousands of dollars per day
okay bankrupt the business within two
weeks yeah that's right it's medical
tyranny
that's right if we don't have the
freedom to choose what we decide is
injected into our body then we've lost
our freedoms altogether
you've got the option in Florida you've
got the option in Texas is that
ultimately what you're going to have to
do I mean I I can't imagine it's exactly
cheap especially if you've got 11 kids I
can't imagine it's cheap to go you know
uh post up a home in Texas for however
long this process will take
so um we're waiting to be expected that
do you actually have to apply to these
trains
donors that have reached out or
potential donors that want to be tested
to see if they can be Julia's match but
we can't send them to a medical center
Duke has cut off our potential donors as
well so we have to get a medical center
set up so that they can go there and be
tested for Julia yes it will be very
expensive for us to have split Ops um
that's why we had a friend set up at
Gibson go for us so that's gives10go.com
backslash kidney for Juliet people have
been so generous to us so many people
have reached out to us and also I just
want to say too that when we got the
microphone I don't know why we got the
microphone because there's a lot of
people in the same situation but we want
to use our microphone to help other
people and so many families have reached
out to us already we've been able to
connect them let them know which medical
centers they need to reach out to to try
to get their loved ones transplants as
well so that's gibsongo.com kidney for
Yulia with a y y u l
so people can go there to help out uh we
also have a website yuliagrace.com and
that's where people can contact us if
they want
um to be a potential donor or if they
you know if there's other medical
centers that we're not aware of yet
um we are hoping this one in Florida
works out but we're still have to wait
and see
well that that's good obviously people
can go donate and pray also praying
would is always a good thing to do
absolutely so that's how you you can
help in that situation there's something
else that I want to do though which is I
want to punish Duke for what they're
doing I think actually it's not not
enough just to just to help the people
who've clearly been victimized here but
you need to make sure that this is not
permitted to continue into the future we
were talking earlier on the show about
retribution and I think Duke deserves
some serious Justice for their crimes
here okay and so from a political
standpoint how do we stop medical
centers from from doing this so we have
retained a lawyer Mike Yoder and he is
working that right now uh appearance of
damages to Duke and uh so we're that's
that's I'm going right now that's what
we're trying to do I know to help to
hold a Duke accountable for this you
know travesty in my mind but people can
call Duke if they want to as well and
let their opinions be known but we just
ask that there's no foul language use or
any death threats um we want to keep
this civil but for Duke to understand
that we're not alone there's other
people in this country that also agree
with what we're doing right and that is
an important point you you've got to
make sure that uh when you engage in
these political actions you don't give
the leftists the opportunity to paint
you as a terrorist or all the way that
they ordinarily talk about us though
conservatives don't really need to be
told this I think conservatives
generally know this but it's always good
to repeat because I I remember not that
long ago here in Nashville we discovered
that Vanderbilt Children's Hospital was
performing transgender procedures on
little kids and this is this is
Tennessee okay we're talking about a
pretty red State here and and we
discovered this and we found it people
just didn't really know about it and so
we we gathered a lot of information my
colleague Matt Walsh has made the
transgender issue something of a hobby
horse of his and had a big movie come
out about it so he just published a
Twitter thread with the the research
that the daily wire had compiled and the
moment we shed a light on this
like within days the Vanderbilt
University just caved because they
didn't want and I I just suspect if if
people in North Carolina taxpayers
donors even to Duke Medical politicians
who have a lot to say about the the
conduct here if they just knew that this
was happening I cannot imagine how it
would be tolerated for much longer I
agree I agree with you we have had a
couple of legislators reach out to us
but we've heard no more from them so I
don't know I hope that something does
happen that we're out as well how is
your daughter doing through all of this
um she's doing amazing she I said on
other interviews too she's the most
amazing little girl she's been through
so much in her life we're her third
family in America uh I mean she's she's
been through so much but she just pushes
through with a smile on her face she's
always happy always wanting to help so
involved with all the other kids in the
family I mean she really is just an
amazing person
you you mentioned that you're the third
family how did you come to adopt her
but uh so the first family they would I
met them in Ukraine in 2018 we adopted
our first uh daughter from Ukraine and
uh there was another family that adopted
him here in North Carolina
that didn't work out they sent uh her to
Arizona to another family to potentially
adopt her it that didn't work out so
they were on the flight on a plane back
to North Carolina the family here that
originally adopted her uh was not able
to go pick them up at the airport so we
did because I knew who they were her and
her brother and so we picked them up at
the airport we thought we were going to
be keeping for a weekend just to kind of
figure out what we're gonna you know who
was going to adopt and what we're gonna
do in the next steps and we ended up
being the family that they uh they ended
up going to so I'm grateful for that I
have total family size Envy right now I
got I got married we got started a
little bit later I I hope to catch up I
think uh it's just a matter of biology
I'm not quite sure we could get up to
eight biological children so you've
adopted as well now your family size is
unusual by today's stand by historical
standards it's not but by modern liberal
Society standards it certainly is what
has impelled you to have such a large
family God
simply answer the God I mean it was
never our plan to have a big family but
my husband was military and we traveled
around the world
um our oldest son kept praying for her
brother and they just kept coming so
there we go three girls three little
girls of seven seven boys we wouldn't
have it any other way though like our
life is crazy and chaotic and amazing
and beautiful
that that is amazing and you mentioned
your uh military service so thank you
thank you for your service it even
drives home the point further than it
already was
in in political stories sometimes the
details are kind of complicated and
these These are nuanced issues and
questions
and sometimes it's just
pretty clear who the good guys are and
the bad guys are and I mean if if you if
you took this story to a Hollywood
producer and you said hey I got this
story about a family military veterans
you know big loving family adopted
children a poor little girl who needs a
kidney transplant and then a bunch of
doctors who out of out of a vindictive
biteful tyranny are demanding that she
inject herself with a dangerous drug or
they won't give her her kidney and and
that's going to be the movie The you
know what the Hollywood producer would
say the producer would say come on it's
a little too on the nose come on let's
make it a little more realistic here
okay
but but this is what's really happening
to you
it is really happening this is real life
yeah have other families all the time
that she used to write her she should
write about her autobiography so maybe
she'll actually get that out of this
well she's a she's a ferocious reader
and she does write books Yeah you
mentioned other families who are in a
similar position have any of them
reached out to you as a result of the
publicity yes just one little boy who's
only two years old in South Carolina and
they are they will not give him a
transplant either without the vaccine
which is unconscionable to me he's two
years old
um I've been talking to that grandfather
a lot we were trying to get him to
another Medical Institute and he's
trying to fight
um The Tyranny down there in South
Carolina as well
I didn't even know the vaccine was
approved for two-year-olds much less I
would mandate it
I know right it's it's horrific I think
the CDC is now recommended down to six
months old yeah for this vaccine six
which is unconscious yeah that's
unconscionable to me I can't believe
that what's amazing about it too I mean
you you say that uh obviously you're a
religious family God is at the center of
of so much that has happened in your in
your family but
humility is the beginning of wisdom the
fear of the Lord is the beginning of
wisdom and you would just think that
after two years of the experts in the
lab coats being proven wrong and in some
cases being proven to have lied about
and and to have been negligent about
this virus and this vaccine repeatedly
time and time again on the safety on the
efficacy on the the way that the
technology would even work on what the
virus is on where the virus came from on
how to stop getting the virus on
everything just every single thing about
it
they might have just a little bit of
humility and loosen their grip and their
demands just a little bit but it seems
that it's only gone in the opposite
direction it seems that they've only
only clamped down even further yeah it's
I really feel like it's a power struggle
at this point like they they want their
way and we're not going to do it so then
they're going to withhold what we need
have you raised significant amount of
money yet to to be able to afford going
to Texas or Florida
yes we really have people have been very
ways very much I mean we're overwhelmed
by the generosity of perfect strangers
and had the words of encouragement that
have come to us um it's been amazing
there have been some nasty comments but
I would say it's ten to one in support
of us of course I can't even imagine who
the nasty comments are from maybe it's
just Dr fauci with his pseudonymous
accounts or something you know what I
mean a lot of times they don't give
their real email it's just like a
made-up email and there's a lot of foul
language and you know but we just delete
it and move on of course of course
that's all that one can really do I mean
I just think from the beginning
especially of this whole covid operation
uh there has been this concerted effort
not only to force people to comply with
their absurd demands but to discourage
people
but to say you can never beat us you
could we we've got all of the Power
we've got all of the cards you you know
that's so much about what you will
comply I think ultimately came down to
is that there were people who didn't had
religious objections to the vaccine who
just knew because they had good guts and
common sense that there was probably
something a little bit weird about this
experimental drug that was concocted in
five minutes and didn't undergo any
long-term trials and but but because
they you know they just didn't want to
they couldn't lose their job some people
they just couldn't lose their job or
they couldn't say no or they were in the
military or they can't for whatever
reason they just went because they fell
into discouragement you have not been
discouraged it's all the Lord like we
really just are leading on God and he's
carrying us through this
um we we we joke that we never know what
our life is going to be from day to day
and it kind of just blew up in the last
week but we really feel like we are
doing what is right and good and we'll
just keep clinging to that
wonderful absolutely wonderful you uh
I'm pleased to say you have not been
discouraged and your story is a great
encouragement to a lot a lot of other
people because
everyone's been up against some pressure
during the the kovid regime
very few people have been up against the
kind of pressure that you were up
against and you've stood firm and and
people have come out to help and people
are standing with you so please head on
over if you are so inclined it's end of
year this is when people start you know
writing checks anyway before New Year's
Eve so head on over to give send Go
slash
so it's gibsongo.com backslash kidney
for Yulia kidney for Yulia Utley Chrissy
thank you both for coming on the show
we'll keep you in our prayers and and uh
hope to see a happy outcome sooner
rather than later
thank you so much and thanks for
of course I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael all show we'll see you next
time